hi I'm Katie and Cory's mom and Chloe I
accidentally became a meme and this is
that story before the viral sensations
it was a normal everyday family like
breakfast TV cartoons trips in 2010 if
we did not have a youtube account we
didn't have any social media except for
Facebook and I knew I want to surprise
my leave with a trip to Disneyland and
my family was all over the country I'm
like you know I'll post it on YouTube so
they can see it hey Lily you want to
open a birthday present early
Lily was five turning six and Chloe was
only a few months old she was just a
baby I made the video saw her reaction
and I just loved it oh I don't really
remember that much from my Disney trip I
did not think for one second that it
would go viral it just doesn't even
cross my mind
I remember feeling like a chicken with
my head cut off because there were so
many different people reaching out all
over and I remember crying myself to
sleep one of the nights because I was so
overwhelmed because one minute your
child is a normal child the next minute
half the world knows who she is it was
pretty insane but it was amazing we had
nothing but a positive experience for me
so I'm like it's been 2 years you know I
I really didn't think we'd be able to
get her again because I mean she's known
for being surprised and but we got her
again and she was crying yes we're going
again
so Chloe didn't even come into my like
mindset at that point with that second
video this time Chloe made the face
which she always made every day it was
nothing new so when I hand over her and
she made the face I didn't think
anything of it I remember sitting in the
car there's a peanut face you do
remember me I recorded it that day
uploaded it that day you went straight
to Disneyland and it was it was insane
it really affected our trip because my
phone was ringing off the hook so I
don't want to wonder how do they get a
hold me that's my question where does it
get my number when we go to Disneyland
and that's where we get recognized the
most in it I can just hear the screaming
like coming out of nowhere and people
just want to see her and meet her and
talk to her and she's always overwhelmed
and she's always just like making the
face probably people were like running a
past past us and oh my gosh I would love
that meme and then my my mom was like
that's her she's like they're like and
then you ran over like please I'm like
she's right here and they're like oh my
god kids wants to do didn't you know
but she's really sweet and the people
are so sweet that we meet I feel like
the second time around social media had
expanded a lot in those tears it's
actually the BuzzFeed article that said
the patron saint of tumblr is Chloe and
I'm like what is the tumblr I had to
really get familiar with tumblr because
people were sending me the weirdest
things I've ever seen I remember the
first time I showed her was something
from tumblr and she was so weirded out
because I was just scrolling and it was
just Chloe on Nicki Minaj Chloe's face
on Miley Cyrus and the wrecking ball
Chloe's face is the wrecking ball
Chloe's face on Beyonce space dancing
and drunken love video like I asked me
as a mom had to get in and see what all
these kids are doing and I show Chloe
and she would be like mom stop me and so
I feel like it hasn't really clicked
until the last like three years you know
when she hit like five and six where
she's like oh wow and people were
noticing her and we go to McDonald's and
people were noticing just her average
everyday life started to change um I
asked my friends if they liked memes and
then they're like oh yeah i love memes
and like the girl with the side-eye face
and I was like yeah that's me and
they're like stop rolling yeah YouTube
channel like just from this point on
it's been like a dream we've been able
to do so many things we've been
Brazil where I'll sleep in Mexico just
so many great places sometime no we went
to Brazil was super fun we did lots of
fun things we met as finally doing magic
tricks with us and like oh yeah we went
to see Google and that was fun and I got
to sign a picture of me oh yeah but over
oh yeah the elevator it's my meme on the
elevator elevator yeah we had to ride
that elevator like 20 times
yeah II had billboards all over herself
Hollow so we just drive around and there
was my child on the Billboard I was just
all the way Disney invite us to a record
rock Chimaera and we went and we walked
the red carpet and like we took pictures
and stuff and we saw the movie it was so
good and like we got to me Penelope
wreck-it Ralph and like all the Disney
Princesses stuff things come in Eva's
and flows sometimes we'll have a really
awesome year we've worked with some
other really fun companies and then the
last few months there's nothing and
we're okay with that there's no you know
trying to make this what it isn't so we
have average day we have movie nights
family nights you know Disneyland trips
and what if we get the amazing
opportunity to do these crazy things I
always tell my girls stop and look
around see where you are like this is
not a normal life
so really enjoy it in the moment if I
could go back I probably would not
change anything because things have been
it's been such a great experience I feel
like nothing could be changed Chloe has
fun Lilly has fun we laugh we joke
there's one thing that I've learned you
cannot control it once it's out its out
and you're never gonna get it back I
think the best thing I can say is just
let it
just be yourself like say kind people
that's that's what I do like my famous
somewhere I just stuff like that a lot
of people want a parent chain me because
I can't believe you put her video on I
have no idea this which happened you
know I didn't plan for it to happen I
definitely didn't plan for Chloe to
become a meat and it happened so the
best thing the best advice I can do just
have fun with it it won't last forever
you know she'll always be the side-eye
but she's growing up and you know
becoming older and I think sometimes
people forget I think with all
celebrities big and small is that Chloe
is just her face is just a picture it's
a second in time you know she isn't a
person
Andy and I playing of my best friend and
my mom signing me up for soccer with my
best friend and that's pretty much all
she's not just a book to side-eye
although she doesn't a lot you know
she's a real little girl and you know
this has been just the funnest thing
ever
so I'm Katie close mom
[Music]